[Music]
what looms on the horizon for Hawkins
Indiana what is vekna's villainous
future plan and seriously what's
happening between will and Mike here are
some of the biggest mysteries The Duffer
Brothers left for us to mull over until
stranger things season five warning
spoilers ahead
11 has a twisted past with the
manipulative mad scientist Martin
Brenner AKA Papa Brenner first orders 11
to make telekinetic contact with the
entity he refers to as the monster way
back in season one this connection
unleashes a demogorgon and cracks open
the mother gate the first known passage
between Hawkins and the upside down with
what we now know about vecna this place
is even more blame on Brenner for the
other worldly consequences that
devastate Hawkins in stranger things 4
Brenner plays a central role in
reactivating 11's telekinetic abilities
but he also shackles her with a
restrictive power inhibiting collar then
before he dies he unlocks the
imprisoning device this final gesture
probably isn't as Redemptive as Brenner
wishes it was after he so recently and
selfishly tried to contain 11 his
motivations are mostly rooted in
self-interest as far as we know
assumedly he knows 11 has to be the one
to defeat vechna and save the world so
he releases her did he truly love 11
like a daughter or is vechna right about
Brenner's primary goal of harnessing
their greatness maybe Brenner does care
for 11 but certainly not in the selfless
way Hopper does though we may have seen
the last of Brenner his mysterious
nature could still haunt the final
season
Noah schnapp did a tremendous job
delicately portraying Will's navigation
of his sexual identity in season 4 and
even appears to enjoy sharing his
thoughts on Stranger Things ships with
fans schnapp has openly discussed the
beauty of portraying Will's experience
though he also says Will's actions leave
room for audience interpretation then
again when will has to pick a heroic
figure from history for a school diorama
project in season 4 he picks Alan Turing
Turing was a brilliant man of math
science and philosophy who was
persecuted for being gay in 1952 rather
than face jail he was chemically
castrated and died from cyanide
poisoning in 1954. while everyone can
admire turing's courage in the face of
homophobia Will's studies of the
mathematician exist within the specific
context of his seemingly unrequited
feelings for Mike feelings that are
especially difficult in the context of
the 1980s at the end of season 4 these
feelings remain unexplored but the
series has seemingly been hinting at
Will's long path towards self-acceptance
since the very first episode look he's
he's a sensitive kid Lonnie Lonnie used
to say he was queer we won't know if
Will's sexuality ever gets openly
addressed and fully celebrated until the
final season but if it does we hope the
poor kid finally finds some peace
the series consistently explores 11's
mysterious origin story though one
crucial question remains unanswered at
the end of stranger things 4. who is
eleven's biological father fan theories
have gone wild since the series
premiered with identities ranging from
Brenner to vekna himself with the final
season on the horizon will we finally
learn the truth there's a case to be
made for both Brenner and vecna the
recent season displayed Empire Strikes
Back like themes with our heroes
suffering devastating losses on the cusp
of an epic final showdown with that in
mind could we get a similar empire style
reveal in season 5 with vekna announcing
that he's 11's dad a Luke I am your
father moment would fit right into
stranger things 80s pop culture collage
and a hereditary telekinetic ability
could explain the strength of her power
as opposed to the other kids at the
Hawkins lab it's also possible Brenner
is her biological father which makes his
electroshock treatments on her mother
even more damning and monstrous in
hindsight if he is her father his
eternalistic feelings might be what
motivates him to remove her collar and
volume 2 then again maybe what matters
most is the father who was there for 11
because that would of course be Hopper
as we learn more and more about the
mythology of stranger things and the
upside down viewers have remained
dedicated to figuring out all the
specific ins and outs in a pivotal
flashback we learned that eleven sent
one to the upside down which is how he
became vecna one detail in particular is
a little unclear at first did eleven
create the entire upside down or just
open the mother gate variety asked
Millie Bobby Brown herself this question
and she provided some much needed
Clarity she said I think that the
alternate universe was always there that
is always going to be under Hawkins I
just think she has access to it I don't
think that she created the upside down
this spine tingling detail puts vekna at
a big Advantage going into season five
with the upside Down's groundbreaking
invasion of Hawkins
speaking of vecna where is he now the
last time we see him in true horror
movie fashion the seemingly dead big bad
has suspiciously vanished we know for a
fact that he's badly injured after
sustaining A Reign of cocktail fire via
Robin and several shotgun blasts from
Nancy but where is he hiding we also
learn more about his ability to
indirectly inhabit other people through
these spore-like smoke of the Mind flare
so it may be a while before we see the
physical form of him again vechna will
surely take his time plotting his next
move while he heals up now that Hawkins
is smoldering and broken can 11 use her
powers to track his physical form or
will he keep the stranger things gang
busy with his vicious underworld
creatures while his spores spread we'll
find out in stranger things season 5
slated for release in 2024 because good
things come to those who wait
the fourth clock Chimes and Hawkins
Falls it's an unthinkable moment
signaling vecna's Victory but it may
have also pointed out an important
location for the final season four Gates
form paths to the upside down and
shatter Hawkins until converging in a
four-way Center but where's the building
they meet at it could be insignificant
but the symbolism of this location would
probably give will Goosebumps the four
paths meet at the Hawkins Public Library
which plays a major role in season one
it's the upside down Nest where the
demogorgon drags will and Barb as well
as numerous other Unfortunate Souls the
most notable and frightening detail of
the library is the unscathed Clock Tower
vekna's icon quickly became the clock
and its dreaded accompanying Chimes that
he forces his victims to see in here
before they die could this be signaling
where the damaged vechna is hiding and
healing the building is covered in Black
vines in the epilogue and will did say
he could feel vekna in Hawkins so it
seems plausible
when Max's limbs began grotesquely
twisting in the manner of vechna's
previous victims many viewers were
stunned stranger things has killed off
fan favorite characters in Prior Seasons
but subjecting spunky teenage Max who
the audience has been getting to know
ever since she's first introduced in
2017 season 2 to a brutally violent
demise would have felt like a grim dark
Choice even by the horror adjacent
standards of stranger things that's why
it's scary when 11 tries to reach Max in
her coma and finds nothing but Darkness
what does this mean for Max there are
two possible options here as far as we
can see in the first max never wakes
from her coma her brain simply died when
her heart stopped in the other scenario
vekna still has a hold of Max's mind the
latter is more probable and we can even
infer that vechna may use her as a
hostage of some kind in the final season
hopefully with the recently announced
time Jump Max will awaken season 5 on
her own if not there may be a time
travel twist awaiting us when stranger
things returns that reverses the events
of the Season 4 Finale remember season 4
confirms the upside down is stuck in
1983.
Steve makes his lasting feelings for
Nancy pretty clear throughout season
four Jonathan and Nancy are still dating
although he's keeping a secret about his
future plans that seems to be pushing
her away the two planned to attend
Emerson College together at one point
but Jonathan intends to save money by
going to Community College while also
keeping an eye on his family and has yet
to break the news Jonathan numbs his
feelings with marijuana and Pizza in
California while Steve struggles with
romance and rewound VHS tapes at Family
Video in Hawkins however Steven Nancy's
recent harrowing Adventures against
vecna may have reignited that spark
between them when Jonathan jokes about
Steve's irresponsibility in the finale
Nancy defends him by saying he's
actually matured a lot he's actually
grown up quite a bit you know
yeah could this be foreshadowing A
Renewed relationship in season five
as Hawkins prepares for The Showdown of
a lifetime who will live to see the very
end the final season could quite
possibly pack a punch if more than a few
beloved characters lose their lives in
the Ultimate Clash against vecna the
most burning question of all is who will
survive this season we tearfully watched
Eddie Munson sacrifice himself in the
finale and die in the arms of Dustin
will this Inspire Dustin to do the same
for his friends next season Steve made
it through season four in one piece but
could he tragically fall victim to
vechna immediately after reuniting with
Nancy could Hopper whose evaded death
countless times finally run out of luck
we've been following these characters
since the premiere of stranger things in
2016. so we would definitely prefer a
happy ending for everybody but in
vecna's Nightmare world that doesn't
seem too likely
in an unforeseen move vechna wins the
battle and achieves his four deaths to
forcibly unite the upside down with
Hawkins his menacing influence starts
taking over the town and draining the
life force out of everything it touches
with flowers reduced to ashy dust eleven
looks over the decaying field with a
determined look that indicates she's
hell-bent on killing vechna for good can
they stop his spores from spreading as
they fall over Hawkins like snow to
reference Star Wars again our Hawkins
Heroes may need to retreat to their own
version of Dagobah and find a master
like Yoda to train with maybe they'll
make their way to Pittsburgh to visit a
certain telekinetic sibling or even
return to California for a much-needed
doobie and a couple slices of surfer Boy
Pizza then again there's a chance
they'll spend some time back in 1983 via
the upside down but we won't know for
sure until stranger things returns for
the fifth and final season
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]